und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und bettina schausten
guten abend elfter januar von heute an
gelten die schärferen corona maßnahmen
deutschlandweit strengere kontakt
beschränkungen etwa doch deutschlandweit
heißt in dieser pandemie immer auch es
ist von bundesland zu bundesland
verschieden
hier ist die 15 kilometer entfernung
regel pflicht dort ist sie bloß
empfehlung
hier sind die schulen geschlossen dort
bleiben sie offen und beim impfen hat
ohnehin jedes land sein eigenes tempo
so begann dieser arbeitswoche für viele
mit der ahnung dass das viel beschworene
ja 20 21 nicht halten könnte was es
silvester noch versprach da war es an
seite mit seinen notizen aus
deutschlands es ist der erste tag
bundesweiten lockdown ab heute gelten
verschärfte kontakt regeln ein haushalt
darf sich nur noch mit einer weiteren
person zu hause treffen diejenigen die
in hannovers innenstadt unterwegs waren
begrüßen die verschärfung
aber nicht jedes auch eine los muss ich
werde mich daran halten auch wenn ich es
nicht verstehe aber ich werde es
trotzdem einhalten ich darf zu meinen
eltern fahren aber meine eltern wirklich
zu mir kommen zu zweit aber ja ich werde
mich daran halten dass es einheitlich
gemacht wird und dann würden durch
fragen die einheitlichkeit in
deutschland leidet an den ausnahmen in
den jeweiligen bundesländern auch in
krefeld leere innenstädte und
geschlossene geschäfte die auf ihrer
winterkollektion sitzenbleiben im
internet machen inhaber auf ihre
situation aufmerksam unter gleichnamigen
hashtag heute öffneten sie ihre läden
kurzum ein foto von sich zu machen
vor ihren unverkäuflichen waren werden
das ist wirklich so dass es kein kinder
für die zukunft irgendwann das wird noch
in diesem jahr passieren
keine 25 kilometer von bonn entfernt
öffnet heinz-gerd ballensiefen seinen
hausen imbiss mehr als essen zum
mitnehmen darf der restaurantbesitzer
nicht verkaufen
durch den verschärften lockdown kommen
immer weniger kunden
das ist unser leben da wir bestreiten
unser leben und alles nach vorne kam
angst wir haben wirklich angst zu haben
existenten existenzängste erst 2009 10
hat er seine mühle liebevoll restauriert
und ordentlich investiert nur eine
abschlagszahlung haben bisher als hilfe
bei ihm an
seit november ist das restaurant zu und
wird es weiter sein fahrt ins
thüringische eichsfeld diese reise ist
ab heute für ausflügler verboten hier
gilt jetzt die 15 kilometer regel ohne
triftigen grund darf niemand mehr in
oder aus dem landkreis fahren
bitter für den skilift betreiber endlich
liegt schnee und nun darf niemand kommen
er flüchtet sich in selbstironie
eigentümer betreiber und lockdown
geschädigt nichts tue im moment also
alles was so negativ zu der boss der
inzidenz fährt im kreis ist jenseits der
500 bürgermeister sven gregor bespricht
sich mit dem leiter des ordnungsamts
kontrollen jahr aber zunächst keine
bußgelder
sie setzen auf einsicht und hoffen dass
niemand aus dem nahen franken anreisen
wird ein spielplatz mitten in münchen
das letzte refugium für milla jovovich
und ihrer fünfjährigen tochter außerhalb
der drei zimmer wohnungen
ihre tochter leidet an asthma und sie
selbst ist wieder schwanger
beides bereitet ihr sorgen in corona
zeiten ich kann nicht mehr
letztes jahr hieß es auch genau so dass
gleich um dieses jahr auch irgendwie
nimmt kein ende
die schwangere mutter ist erschöpft wie
viele menschen in deutschland und dabei
ist heute erst tag eins des verschärften
londons eltern und kinder fühlten sich
heute vielerorts ins frühjahr des
letzten jahres versetzt als die schulen
in der ersten ko-runde welle neuland
betraten homeschooling leider zu häufig
im digitalen nirwana
doch selbst wo die lernplattformen
inzwischen funktionieren bleibt häufig
ein betreuungsproblem für berufstätige
eltern die nicht im home office arbeiten
können hessen zum beispiel lässt auch
deshalb für kinder bis zur sechsten
klasse die schulen offen bietet
betreutes lernen an mit welchen folgen
wird die notbetreuung zum regelbetrieb
damit niklas meister berichtet es ist
ein anderer schulstart als sonst nach
den ferien eigentlich sollten die
schulen geschlossen bleiben
doch es gibt keine einheitliche linie in
den ländern
so können in hessen eltern die arbeiten
müssen ihre kinder zur schule schicken
zumindest in den unteren jahrgängen an
der robert schumann grundschule
organisiert katharina hatte ich bin nun
beides den fernunterricht für die kinder
zu hause und die betreuung in der schule
für die lehrerinnen und lehrer eine
herausforderung der versuchen wir
gerecht zu werden indem wir einerseits
die schülerinnen und schüler die zu
hause betreut werden können mit einem
gut strukturierten unterrichtsmaterial
versorgen
dazu nutzen wir zum beispiel digitale
pinnwände wochenpläne und wir haben eine
material schleuse eingerichtet auf der
anderen seite versorgen wir die kinder
die eben zu uns kommen und an
präsenzunterricht teilnehmen mit
demselben material etwa 40 prozent der
kinder waren heute morgen anwesend in
der wiesbadener grundschule im schnitt
waren es in ganz hessen etwa ein fünftel
bis klassenstufe 6 die schülerinnen und
schüler bearbeiten die gleichen aufgaben
blätter wie die kinder im homeschooling
unterricht findet nicht statt nur bei
fragen hilft die lehrerin
die eltern können darüber jetzt
wöchentlich entscheiden die gewerkschaft
gew sieht das kritisch viele eltern
haben angst dass ihre kinder etwas
verpassen eltern sagen auch kinder
können zu hause nicht gut lernen und
eltern sind auch wenn sie im home office
sind ja trotzdem arbeiten und wissen
auch oft nicht wie sie diese situation
miteinander verknüpfen sollen das
hessische kultusministerium appelliert
an die eltern ihre kinder waren immer
möglich nicht in die schule zu schicken
überlässt dabei anders als bei der
schulschließung im frühjahr die
entscheidung den eltern
es liegt vor allem daran hat man bei dem
druck betreuungssystem dann von
staatswegen entscheiden muss welche
eltern betreuungsbedarf geltend machen
können und welche nicht
und diese entscheidungen wollten wir
vermeiden
da wollen wir eigentlich wirklich die
eltern fragen sagt den eltern noch
richten wir diesen bedarf für sich
selbst sieht wir diesen bedarf hat
kritiker sagen das kultusministerium
lasse die eltern mit der entscheidung
allein gerade in der grundschule aber
benötigen kinder die meiste
aufmerksamkeit digitales lernen sei
schwierig bei den kleinsten berichten
eltern
die belastung ist enorm hoch vor allen
dingen in der grundschule man muss ich
wahnsinnig gut strukturieren wir gehen
oft abends schon die aufgaben durch für
die nächsten tag arbeiten mit post-its
gucken was die kinder dann noch an
unterstützung brauchen und am nächsten
morgen muss dann einer von beiden in der
grundschule bei den kindern
unterstützung leisten die können das
noch nicht alleine die schulschließungen
sind ein spagat möglichst viele kinder
und jugendliche sollen zu hause bleiben
gleichzeitig aber fehlt es an entlastung
für berufstätige eltern ja wie soll das
gehen die kinder am küchentisch lernen
zu lassen wenn die eltern im büro im
betrieb in der produktionshalle arbeiten
müssen und was nutzt es gegen die
verbreitung des virus das die
arbeitswelt bisher weitgehend
ausgenommen ist von strikten regelungen
darüber ist eine debatte entbrannt und
in der haben sich heute auch die grünen
positioniert auf ihrer
jahresauftaktklausur in zwei jahr 20 21
in berlin begrüße ich jetzt die
vorsitzende annalena baerbock
schönen guten abend also eine pflicht
zum home office wollen sie
hängen das hätte man heute von ihnen ist
das mehr als der appell den der
bundesarbeitsminister heil heute an
unternehmen überhaupt an die wirtschaft
richtet also sie wollen frau berger com
office als zwangsmaßnahme nein nicht als
zwangsmaßnahme aber überall dort wo es
möglich ist als gebot dass menschen zu
hause arbeiten damit sie nicht den
öffentlichen nahverkehr nutzen müssen wo
wir nach wie vor ja volle züge haben und
vor allen dingen damit sie nicht in
großraumbüros sitzen weil es ja schon
etwas absurd ist dass wir im privaten
auf den niedrigen kontakt runter gehen
aber dann menschen nach wie vor in
großraumbüros arbeiten gerade in vielen
verwaltung weiterhin ins büro fahren und
wenn wir nach großbritannien schauen
wenn wir nach england oder auch dänemark
schauen diese mutation die dort gerade
sich massiv ausbreitet das sind
eigentlich die waren bilder die wir im
frühjahr aus bergamo hatten sie sagen
keine zwangsmaßnahmen aber doch muss es
ja irgendwie umgesetzt werden wenn sie
sagen dass sollte verpflichtend sein
wie wollen sie das machen also bußgelder
verhängen kann sich die wirtschaft
darauf einstellen sollte sich die
wirtschaft darauf einstellen seit erstem
erst jetzt möglich dass im arbeitsrecht
angesichts dieser pandemie per
verordnung unternehmen auferlegt werden
kann dass es ein gebot zum home office
gibt das heißt überall wo es möglich ist
für manche mitarbeitenden ist das nicht
möglich wenn er zu hause überhaupt gar
keine situation hat von dort zu arbeiten
keine infrastruktur aber bei ganz ganz
vielen bereichen ist es halt möglich und
dort dann all diejenigen arbeitenden
wirklich auch zu hause arbeiten zu
lassen das könnte der arbeitsminister
mit dieser verordnung jetzt anordnen ja
aber nicht wirklich so ran will an
dieses thema die wand wirtschaft warnt
natürlich jetzt schon vor
zwangsmaßnahmen aber auch der verdi chef
zum beispiel wernicke der sagt das ist
alles schwierig für beschäftigte oft
haben die nicht mal einen platz für den
schreibtisch zu hause also bitte nicht
verpflichtend machen ja einfach ist es
gerade ja für niemanden dass es
vollkommen klar und die one size fits
all lösung also die eine super lösung
für alle die wird es nicht geben aber
wir müssen jetzt schauen wie wir ganz
pragmatisch in allen bereichen dafür
sorgen können dass die kontakte massiv
reduziert werden
und mich an gerade in den letzten tagen
noch mal ganz ganz viele zuschriften
auch erreicht wo arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer sagen wir möchten gerne zu
hause sein aber dann müssen wir doch ins
büro kommt es wäre eigentlich möglich
und deswegen überall wo es möglich ist
soll es jetzt auch stattfinden wie
gesagt in dem einzelfall
wo hat ein arbeitnehmer dann sagt das
geht aber zu hause nicht ich kann das
nicht weil ich mit zwei zimmer wohnung
habe und hier noch zwei kleine kinder
dann kann der auch in sein einzel büro
kommen aber alle wo das möglich ist dann
muss es auch entsprechend umgesetzt
werden weil jeder einzelne kontakt zählt
in dieser wahnsinnig schwierigen
situation der home auf fest das
erleichtert natürlich auf den ersten
blick auf die situation für eltern die
dann kinder womöglich zu hause betreuen
wir müssen aber sie wissen dass auch das
ist natürlich eigentlich keine lösung
beides gleichzeitig ist schwer zu
vereinbaren oft genug landet das problem
dann bei den frauen den müttern die der
dänen eine doppelbelastung zu belastet
wird angelastet wird das nehmen sie auch
in kauf müssten die grünen nicht
kreative ideen entwickeln
ja das ist ja nicht nur der einzige
vorschlag den wir gerade gemacht hat
parallel dazu müssen wir viele weitere
maßnahmen ergreifen zum beispiel dass
wir die gesamte gesellschaft mit ffp
zwei masken jetzt ausstatten dass
diejenigen die nach wie vor im
öffentlichen nahverkehr unterwegs sind
mit den masken unterwegs sind
die bestmöglich schützen wir müssen
zudem dafür sorgen dass die schnelltests
die man jetzt ja selber auch anwenden
kann da hat sich ja auch ganz ganz viel
getan in den letzten wochen dass man
selber schnelltest machen kann
vorne im rachenbereich nicht mehr so
weit hinten dass sie auch für die eigene
anwendung zugelassen werden dass
diejenigen eltern die ihre kinder in die
notbetreuung schicken müssen und das war
mir in den letzten wochen auch wichtig
das angebot muss weiter bestehen auch
für die kinder die zu hause nicht
beschult werden können weil eben kein
laptop da ist die müssen auch nach wie
vor in der schule beschult werden können
dann sollten dort auch diese
schnelltests für personal zugelassen
werden also da wäre jetzt der
gesundheitsminister gefragt eben diese
anwendung für die selbstanwendung von
schnelltests für die entsprechenden
fachkräfte auch zu gewährleisten
vorschläge aus der opposition an die
regierung vielen dank
den erwerbern danke ebenso alles gute
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen am abend aufgezeichnet ja
mehr zur debatte bei den grünen jetzt
auch bei k s oliver richter
denn die grünen haben nicht nur
kurzfristige corona maßnahmen gefordert
sondern auch langfristige konsequenzen
aus der pandemie dafür solle der staat
in den kommenden zehn jahren 500
milliarden euro zur verfügung stellen
heißt es in einem papier des
parteivorstands unter anderem müsse in
effizientere verwaltungen schulen oder
kultur investiert werden
außerdem brauche es bessere bedingungen
bei der pflege und ein neues
finanzierungskonzept für kliniken hartz4
wollen die grünen durch eine garantie
sicherung ersetzen für alle deren
vermögen und einkommen nicht ausreichen
in deutschland sind die ersten dosen des
corona impfstoffes von moderner
angekommen
es ist der zweite impfstoff der in der
eu zugelassen ist und wird ähnlich wie
der impfstoff von beyond
ex-gesundheitsminister sparen sagte im
zdf es werde vorerst keine wahlfreiheit
zwischen den einzelnen impfstoffen geben
dafür sei die menge noch zu klein
bis ende märz rechnet die
bundesregierung mit zwei millionen dosen
des us herstellers
die bundesregierung will labore dazu
verpflichten gezielt nach
hochansteckenden virus varianten zu
suchen
dafür sollen 200 millionen euro
bereitgestellt werden
das gesundheitsministerium bereitet eine
verordnung vor die eine so genannte
gensequenzierung bei positiven corona
tests zur pflicht macht damit reagiert
die regierung auf virus varianten die in
großbritannien und südafrika entdeckt
wurden und sich deutlich schneller
ausbreiten als die bisherigen varianten
der tourismusbeauftragte der
bundesregierung bara ist rechnet nicht
damit dass in den osterferien
urlaubsreisen möglich sein werden besser
werde es erst ab pfingsten sagte er rtl
und n tv mit blick auf den sommer zeigte
sich bahr ist optimistisch wenn bis
dahin die meisten menschen geimpft sein
könnten sogar fernreisen möglich sein so
weit ist die lage im zielland erlaube
staats- und regierungschefs aus aller
welt haben zu mehr
klima und artenschutz aufgerufen beim
virtuellen one planet gipfel die
teilnehmer sagten knapp zwölf milliarden
euro für die sogenannte grüne mauer zu
dafür sollen in der sahel-zone tausende
kilometer bäume gepflanzt werden
in einem streifen von dschibuti bis zum
senegal die natürliche barriere soll die
ausbreitung der sahara stoppen und so
dürren und hungersnöte verhindern
bislang scheiterte das projekt an
fehlendem geld
der countdown läuft noch neun tage bis
donald trump das weiße haus verlassen
muss bis sein nachfolger joe biden
vereidigt wird
und die bange frage in washington ist
was kann trump in neun tagen noch
anrichten einem land schaden zufügen
dass ihm die wählerinnen und wähler vor
vier jahren anvertraut hatten die
demokraten haben ihre ankündigung heute
heute taten folgen lassen und zwei wege
beschritten den präsidenten aus dem amt
zu entfernen
selbst wenn das erst nach seiner
amtszeit gelingen sollte hätte es große
symbolische und sehr konkrete wirkung
peter jäger eine resolution für eine
amtsenthebung des us-präsidenten
eingebracht von den demokraten im
repräsentantenhaus
der vorwurf anstiftung zum aufruhr
donald trump habe die integrität des
demokratischen systems bedroht die
friedliche machtübergabe verhindert eine
gleichrangige staatsgewalt gefährdet
heißt es zeitgleich fordern die
demokraten in einer weiteren resolution
von vizepräsident pence us-präsident vom
vorzeitig aus dem amt zu entfernen
die resolution fordert vizepräsident
michael pence auf die mitglieder des
kabinetts einzuberufen und den
präsidenten mit dem 25 verfassungszusatz
für unfähig zu erklären seine
amtsgeschäfte auszuführen
fraglich ob der vizepräsident der
aufforderung bis morgen folgen wird und
so könnte das demokratisch geführte
repräsentantenhaus nun wohl am mittwoch
über die amtsenthebung trans abstimmen
wir müssen klarmachen dass das was am
mittwoch passiert ist konsequenzen haben
muss
die die sagen wir sollten unseren
auf etwas anderes pflichten einfach
weitermachen die meinen im prinzip das
was passiert ist ist okay die demokraten
wollen mit der amtsenthebung vor allem
sein politisches comeback verhindern
dem künftigen präsidenten beiden aber
dadurch den start in sein amt nicht
erschweren
die idee das verfahren im senat erst
nach den ersten 100 tagen der neuen
regierung zu eröffnen bügelt beiden
heute ab in der ersten hälfte des tages
kümmern wir uns um die amtsenthebung in
der zweiten hälfte nominieren und
verteidigen wie meine leute und
besprechen ein neues hilfspaket
unterdessen meldete sich arnold
schwarzenegger zu wort er vergleicht die
gewalt am kapitol mit der
reichspogromnacht mittwoch war die nacht
des zerbrochenen glas es hier in den
vereinigten staaten
sie sind auf den prinzipien
herumgetrampelt auf denen die usa
gegründet worden sind das capitol ist
abgeregelt auch das washington monument
bleibt bei beiden vereidigung
geschlossen
höchste alarmbereitschaft in washington
die letzten tage mit trump im weißen
haus noch turbulenter als befürchtet ja
und das wollen wir noch vertiefen mit
unserer washington korrespondentin ines
trams jain es welche aussichten hat das
amtsenthebungsverfahren jetzt so auf den
allerletzten metern die chance ist da
und groß dass die demokraten durchziehen
mit der idee des
amtsenthebungsverfahrens im
abgeordnetenhaus schon am mittwoch
dieser woche könnten sie es mit
einfacher mehrheit beschließen die
demokraten hätten dann erreicht dass
präsident trump abgestraft würde zur
rechenschaft gezogen würde mit einem
zweiten amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
ihn die demokraten sehen ja trump als
geistigen brandstifter für den sturm
aufs kapital eher unwahrscheinlich
allerdings ist dass die notwendige
zweidrittel mehrheit im senat dafür
zusammenkommt 17 republikaner müssten
die demokraten dafür auf ihre seite
ziehen dass es dann doch eher
unwahrscheinlich und damit ist ebenfalls
unwahrscheinlich dass verhindert werden
kann dass schon jemals wieder für ein
öffentliches amt ein bundesamt antreten
würde
denn genau dafür ist das notwendig eine
an
im senat ja und birgt das ganze nicht
zudem die gefahr dass trump in den augen
seiner anhänger zum märtyrer gemacht
wird geradezu richtig ich denke auf
jeden fall ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
würde von trans anhängern gesehen
verstanden werden als eine rache der
demokraten ein
im pitch mend würde genau wie auch schon
zuvor dass twitter verbot gegen jump als
rache der demokraten gesehen und könnte
schon zum märtyrer machen und würde
trumps anhänger noch weiter von der
etablierten washingtoner politik
entfernen als sie es eh schon sind
generell birgt ein solches impeachment
ja das risiko dass das land und politik
gleichermaßen zerreißt und dabei wäre es
ja eigentlich die zu vorderste aufgabe
für den neuen präsidenten
die gesellschaft wieder zu einen und
brücken zu bauen
danke ihnen es nach washington und jetzt
noch einmal nachrichten mit kaiser ja da
bleiben wir indirekt beim us präsidenten
twitter hatte ja das konto von donald
trump gesperrt und das sorgt für
diskussionen auch in deutschland so
sagte regierungssprecher seibert
bundeskanzlerin merkel halte es für
problematisch wenn solche schritte nicht
innerhalb eines gesetzlichen rahmens
erfolgten die meinungsfreiheit als
grundrecht von elementarer bedeutung
könne nur durch den gesetzgeber
eingeschränkt werden nicht nach der
maßgabe von unternehmen der korona
shutdown fordert weiterhin seinen tribut
nun ist auch die modehändler adler die
luft ausgegangen
das unternehmen hat einen
insolvenzantrag gestellt und steht damit
exemplarisch für viele einzelhändler
walhalla viele einzelhändler ganz
besonders betroffen allerdings die
modebranche denn anders als restaurants
die der shutdown ja auch hart trifft ist
das abhol geschäft bei bekleidung
natürlich schwierig auch ist die
frühlingsmode oft schon bestellt und
muss jetzt bezahlt werden ja und auf der
wintermode bleiben die läden haufenweise
sitzen eine halbe milliarde
kleidungsstück geschätzt man also alles
nicht ganz so einfach vor allem da es
vielen unternehmen schon vor krone nicht
besonders gut gegangen ist auch wegen
der konkurrenz durch den online-handel
nun hat das also das traditionsgeschäft
adler erwischt weil der umsatz wegen
kourou
eingebrochen ist insolvenz wegen
überschuldung allerdings mit dem ziel
das unternehmen zu sanieren
der geschäftsbetrieb soll erstmal
fortgeführt werden adler gehört zu den
größten textileinzelhändler deutschlands
zählte zuletzt über 3000 mitarbeiter und
betreibt in deutschland 142 geschäfte
und einen online handel
der zweite shutdown entwickelt sich zum
desaster für die bekleidungsbranche
neben adler mussten auch esprit
hallhuber und andere insolvenz anmelden
der einzelhandel spricht von
gravierenden schäden des shutdowns
50.000 geschäfte stecken laut verband in
existenznot eine viertel million
arbeitsplätze stünden auf dem spiel
sie fordern mehr und vor allem
schnellere staatshilfe vor allem aber
wünscht sich der einzelhandel eine klare
perspektive
wann ist wie weitergeht danke an die
börse valerie in deutschland ist die
zahl der meisten meldepflichtigen
infektionskrankheiten zuletzt deutlich
zurückgegangen
dazu gehören grippe windpocken oder
erkrankungen durch noroviren zwischen
märz und anfang august registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 35 prozent weniger
fälle als zu erwarten gewesen wäre
ein grund seien die korona maßnahmen ein
anderer die geringere zahl von
fernreisen
so gab es auch weniger malaria fälle
häufiger habe man nur die
hirnhautentzündung fsme registriert die
von zecken übertragen wird
nach den heftigen schneefällen leidet
spanien nun unter einer kältewelle
und wieder ist madrid betroffen dort
sollen die temperaturen in den kommenden
nächten weit unter minus zehn grad
fallen
deshalb bleiben schulen geschlossen und
der nahverkehr gut
das andere extrem bekommt griechenland
zu spüren bei temperaturen von bis zu 31
grad verbrachten viele trotz corona
lockdown ihren tag am strand und das
mitten im januar in diesen wochen jährte
sich ein ereignis zum 125 mal ohne dass
die welt nicht wäre was sie ist ohne
dass die menschen ihre träume nicht
bebildern könnten jedenfalls nicht so
wie es die laufenden bilder der brüder
lumia von anfang an
das kino dieser magische ort der in eine
andere welt entführt sobald das licht
erlischt und der vorhang sich öffnet
allein und doch nicht allein ein
emotionales gemeinschaftserlebnis für
das das heimkino zu hause kaum ersatz
ist da mag der bildschirm noch so groß
sein und doch ist jetzt in corona zeiten
das kino in ernster gefahr
die bundesregierung hat die hilfen für
kleine häuser gerade auf 25 millionen
euro aufgestockt schwer wird es aber für
den mittelbau und auch die großen häuser
wo jetzt eigentlich die blockbuster
anlaufen würden über den kampf einer
ganzen branche
sabine schulz ruhig 007
das fragen wir uns schon lange james der
neue james bond gruner bedingt wieder
und wieder verschoben
zwangspause für die kinos seit monaten
kein umsatz nur kosten nicht alle werden
die krise überstehen einige haben schon
aufgegeben hilfspakete des bundes
sollten die kinobesitzer über den
zweiten shut down retten
manchen hilft vielen nicht oft liegt es
am kleingedruckten hans joachim flebbe
betreibt kinos in acht städten darunter
das ari in münchen und der berliner zoo
palast achtmal miete gehälter verluste
dennoch gilt er als einheitsgesellschaft
für alle acht standorte gibt es nur ein
überbrückungsgeld
wir sind total frustriert und das ist
der ganze kino mittelstand das von der
zugesagten hilfe so gut wie nichts
angekommen ist und wir sind absolut
ärgerlich weil wir ja auch gar keine
chance haben mit den entscheidern mutter
zu sprechen was da schief gelaufen ist
soul heißt das neue abenteuer der disney
pixar animation studios mit witz und
charme und klugen einblicken in die
menschliche seele ein feuerwerk an
fantasie nur nicht im kino sondern für
kunden des hauseigenen streaming
dienstes die pandemie verstärkt den
streaming trennt nur noch couch
stadtkino die besucher dann nach monaten
metrics konsum dann wieder ins kino
gehen wenn sie verstellen sie haben was
vermisst bilder für die große leinwand
der großartige film des iraners rasoulof
das böse gibt es nicht über gehorsam und
widerstand in einem autoritären regime
auch der berlinale gewinner hat es im
november nicht mehr ins kino geschafft
jetzt liegt er auf halde herbe einbußen
für den kleinen verein fehlen der den
film herausbringt kein autor kann sein
buch direkt in die buchhandlung tragen
sondern es braucht halt irgendwie einen
verlag der sein sortiment
zusammengestellt der da auch eine
gewisse inhaltliche ausrichtung mit
transportiert ohne die fans kein kino
und ohne überbrückungsgeld bald keine
verleihe
viele der rund 40 unabhängigen deutschen
verleiher fallen durchs raster sie
nichts von den corona hilfen schon gar
nicht für internationale kino perlen
jenseits deutscher film fördersysteme
ich glaube jetzt muss einfach geschaut
werden dass man die verleiht die diese
kulturell wichtigen filme ins kino
bringen halt irgendwo mitnimmt und ja
das kann sein
ich glaube wir sind da irgendwo hinten
runtergefallen kann das kino corona
überleben was fehlt ist ein
konstruktiver dialog zwischen politik
und kinofilm branche und ein
kassenknüller wie james park
der sollen ab april kinos wieder füllen
wenn es denn diesmal klappt und die
pandemie das zulässt wenn wir das nicht
gut
wird es nichts mehr zu retten geben
doch die hoffnung stirbt bekanntlich
zuletzt
ja so ist es und bis dahin helfen wir
den trennungsschmerz zu mildern immer in
der zdf mediathek und hier jetzt eben
zdf montagskino dann kirk ein spannendes
kriegsdrama über die rettung britischer
soldaten aus dem kessel von dünkirchen
1940 soll sich sehr lohnen
eindrucksvolles kino wo viel von uns für
heute
allerdings ist der nachrichten tag noch
nicht vorbei deshalb lohnt sich um 8.12
noch das heute schon ein update mit
nazan göttinger bis bahn
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein neues jahrzehnt hat begonnen
die gelegenheit also mal zuschauen wie
die letzten 10 jahren im vergleich zu
den jahrzehnten zuvor war und was man ja
eindeutig sieht die temperatur ist immer
weiter gestiegen das folgende jahrzehnt
war immer wärmer als das vorherige und
wie man hier sieht die letzten zehn
jahre waren besonders warm also die
tendenz ist eindeutig es wird immer
wärmer in deutschland und das ist die
analyse des deutschen wetterdienstes
schauen wir mal auf das wetter in
deutschland schon da bekommen wir von
norden regen und dieser regen geht
allmählich in schnee über hier über der
mitte deutschlands und setzt sich morgen
weiter in den süden durch und das ganze
im detail von südwest nach nordost in
diesem streckenbereich müssen sie mit
glätte rechnen durch schnee aber auch
durch glatteis im nordwesten und im
norden viele wolken mit regen im süden
kommt der schnee später an dass bei
temperaturen von minus zwölf grad an den
alpen und 5 grad an der nordsee dort ist
es am mildesten morgen im tagesverlauf
setzt sich der schnee weiter allmählich
in den süden durch im nordwesten lockert
es auf hier kommt sogar die sonne hervor
der wind ist teilweise kräftig aus
nordwest im süden kräftig aus südwest
und weiterhin müssen sie mit schnee
glätte rechnen bei höchsten temperaturen
von null grad im vogtland und 8 grad im
westen deutschlands
die kommenden tage am mittwoch gibt es
weiteren regen und schnee bei minus 1
bis 6 grad ab donnerstag wird es kälter
und der schnee fällt hauptsächlich in
den südlichen landesteilen damit einen
schönen abend